c'est quoi votre meilleur prix parce que
là où il fera pas
les joies de la négociation sont de
retour dans la vieille ville de belfort
un vrai bonheur pour martine et jean
marc des chineurs habitués on est
content de retrouver des puces ça
faisait un petit moment
voilà l'ambiance enquête
on n'a pas le soleil mais c'est pas mal
n'est fait les frais la femme a chiné un
petit peu hors d'eau hors de la brocante
parce qu'elle va régulièrement dans des
dans des magasins drogue etc
moi moi donc donc ouais ça me fait
plaisir de recommencer
on vous suit alors un compteur c'est
aussi redonner vie à des vieux objets
une joie aussi pour les exposants qui
retrouve enfin leurs clients après plus
de trois mois d'arrêt à cause du
confinement
ça fait plaisir de rencontrer clients
mais surtout ça fait plaisir de
retravailler et d'exercer notre métier
d'un brocanteur dong est aussi un métier
de contact et de rencontres entre
passionnés et donc la réouverture de
belfort contribuer à redonner un peu de
dynamique à notre métier qui est en
grande difficulté
ce dimanche ils sont nombreux à flâner à
la découverte d'éventuels coups de coeur
mais crise sanitaire oblige des mesures
ont été prises masque obligatoire pour
les exposants et gels hydro alcooliques
sur chaque stand
les clients sont pas obligées de porter
des masques par contre le marchand est
obligé mais moi je reste à distance
voilà pour des raisons de sécurité c'est
vrai que c'est mieux
et puis si je sais que j'ai touché
quelque chose à manger et le gel qui à
disposition en cliquant n'ont pas de
masque je leur en offrait gracieusement
et puis pour ma part je veux masque
directement et c'est terminé
une manière de sécuriser le marché aux
puces de belfort et ses 140 exposants
l'un des plus importants de l'est de la
france